كتبت بوست كشفت فيه عن احدى صدمات حياتها
ثم انتحرت ما القصه
[موسيقى]
بمحافظه البحيره وتحديدا ايتاي البارود
تفاجئ الناس بصوت ارتطام جسد فتاه لم
يتعدى عمرها ال 24 سنه بالارض بعد ما سقطت
من شرطه منزلها وبيقال انها كانت افضل
انهاء حياتها
علياء بنت محبوبه ومعروف عنها خفه الدم
فجاه اصدقائها ببوس كتبته على حسابها
بموقع فيسبوك كشفت فيه عن احدى صدمات
حياتها اللي اخفتها لسنوات وهي تحرش ابن
عمها بها
واكتملت الصدمه لما لقيت لوالدها وما
صدقهاش ولا دعمها في رجوع حقها وبعد ما
كتبت علياء البوست انتشر بشكل واسع في
خلال دقائق وطالب رواد السوشيال ميديا
برجوعها حق علياء ولكن للاسف علياء فرقه
الحياه بعد نشر الفوز وتم تداول انها قررت
الانتحار ومخارقه الدنيا بصدمتها
وسط تعليقات التعازي والمواساه اثار الخبر
غضب كثير من رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اللي بداوا في نشر حملات بطلبوا فيها
بتصديق الناجيات وبالتقرب من الابناء
ودعمهم علشان ما يوصلوش للمرحله دي من
القلم والضغط النفسي وكمان قررت بعض
الفتيات ذكر مواقف مشابهه مر بها في
حياتهم وازاي يتصرفوا فيها وقتها وحجم
الاذى نفسي اللي تعرضوا له
[موسيقى]
وتباشر النيابه العامه الان تحقيقاتها في
وفاه علياء عامر بعد ما استمعت الاقوال
والدها واخواتها وبعض اقاربها وانت هتحاصل
اقوالهم الى وجود خلافات اسريه بين علياء
ووالدها مسابقه تعرض علياء منذ سنوات
لتحرش من احد اقاربها واكيد التحريات
الشرطه عدم وجود شبه جنائيه في الواقعه
وانها هي اللي القت بنفسها من شرفه مسكنها
وجار استكمال التحقيقات لكشف حقيقه
الواقعه
[موسيقى]